CBS News has learned investigators hired
by Amazon CEO Jeff Bezos have now turned
over their findings to law enforcement
they are investigating how the National
Enquirer obtained private photos and
messages from Bezos last week the
billionaire claimed the Enquirer had
explicit messages images and was trying
to blackmail him that came weeks after
the tabloid revealed Bezos was having an
affair with former TV host Lauren
Sanchez Errol Barnett is here with new
details on the investigation
Errol good morning good morning things
are now coming into clearer focus but
this remains a highly contentious issue
a lawyer for the Enquirer's parent
company says it is the real victim of
bezos's defamatory claims but Bezos and
his team of investigators say this was
all part of an extortion plot and they
are zeroing in on Sanchez's brother as
the possible source of the leak even
though he denies such an allegation they
believe political motivation was likely
a factor I'm not gonna answer who the
source was it was somebody close to both
Bezos Emma Sanchez on Sunday Elkin
Abramowitz the attorney for the parent
company for National Enquirer
stopped short of revealing the source of
the leaks but one source close to Jeff
Bezos his private investigators tell CBS
News they've conducted multiple
interviews with Michael Sanchez the
brother of Bezos his own girlfriend
they say Sanchez a trump supporter
discussed the matter with Roger stone
and caught a page two of mr. Trump's
tortious defenders contacted by CBS News
a person close to Michael Sanchez
dismissed allegations of his involvement
as quote sloppy leaks and crazy
conservative conspiracy theories if I
was conducting an investigation I'd be
starting with mustachios CBS News law
enforcement analyst Paul violist thinks
someone Lauren Sanchez confided in was
the likely leaker the highest
probability of riskier where this leak
came from would be Sanchez and and
whether it was her brother whether it
was a friend when it was anybody in
emails released by Bezos last week
Enquirer officials purportedly claimed
to have a naked selfie in other loot
images of Bezos they offered not to
publish them if the Amazon CEO dropped
his invest
nation I hope common sense can prevail
and quickly one email read it was part
of a legitimate the negotiation each
side had something that they wanted
Abramowitz says the tabloid wanted Bezos
to stop falsely claiming its coverage of
his affair was politically motivated he
also denied the explicit photos are part
of a blackmail plot Bezos and the
newspaper he owns the Washington Post a
frequent targets of President Donald
Trump the National Enquirer is published
by another Trump ally David pecker on
Friday the White House distanced the
president from the controversy we're not
gonna get into a conversation about
something between Jeff Bezos and a
tabloid magazine regardless of how the
texts were leaked viola says he
surprised someone as high-profile as
Bezos wasn't better protected I am
stunned there is no question about it
for somebody like mr. Bezos to be
operating in such a rudimentary fashion
with respect to electronic
communications is shocking to say the
least
now Bezos says blackmail claims are now
being investigated by federal
prosecutors here in New York who you
remember just last year granted The
Enquirer immunity in a separate
investigation into hush money payments
for president Trump's alleged affairs
now they of course could revoke that
immunity if they do determine that the
the organization broke the law in this
instance but that's yet to be determined
it's just very messy arrow all the way
around various storylines exactly the
tune it's not over yet hashtag hot mess
the world will be continued for sure the
world still surprised by that medium
block last debate no thank you Errol